müssen die Deutsche Gesellschaft für
Ernährung denkt über eine Empfehlung
nach nur noch 10 Gramm Fleisch pro Tag
also eine Scheibe Wurst gute Idee also
erstmal dürfen Sie morgens mittags
abends Fleisch essen und sich
ausschließlich von Fleisch in den wenn
Sie wollen können Sie sich auch einen
Wecker stellen der sie nachts jede halbe
Stunde dran erinnert dass hier
fleischpensum aufrecht erhalten das
dürfen Sie alles ob das für Ihre
Gesundheit gut ist das Klima gutes das
ist normal auf dem anderen Blatt
ist unabhängig da sitzen Wissenschaft
also Deutsche Gesellschaft für Ernährung
und da hat ein wissenschaftlernen Papier
gemacht und andere waren andere Papiere
und die machen Empfehlungen an die
Politik wenn sie sagt doch was ist ein
perfektes Beispiel
der Ministerpräsident Freistaates Bayern
schreibt ich würde quasi das Vorstellen
genau
Leute Angst machen möchte
[Musik]